well John you're stuck here now now that
we are officially quarantined here in LA
what we should have done is gone
mattress shopping with key & peele
before they closed all the stores down
now that's a way to spend the apocalypse
but before we go into this thank you to
SiteLock for sponsoring this video guys
it's always important to use protection
especially when you're surfing the web
for completely legitimate reasons of
course yeah not Greg's weird reasons
between all of our passwords credit card
information work emails etc a ton of
important information travels through
our phones and computers every single
day that's some pretty important info it
would be a shame if it were to fall into
the wrong hands
yeah I'm getting there that's where
SiteLock comes in handy site lock offers
cyber security solutions for all levels
of online activity and one of their very
best features is the SiteLock VPN o VPN
like a virtual private network yes Greg
are you mad at me or something whether
you're working from home school or an
airport site LOC will generate a random
server for all of your info to travel
through unnoticeably untraceable it's
the perfect way to master online
activity from the prying eyes of
criminals advertisers and governments
alike I hate you Greg site log is easy
to use and one subscription covers up to
five devices so hit that link down in
the description box to save yourself 40%
on a site lock plan starting at just 349
a month what are you waiting for people
do - you - go away what is your deal you
took some of my favorite talking points
[Music]
welcome to puppet masters Liquidators
how can I help you today I need to buy a
new bed okay good good you came to the
right place I'd be more than happy to
check what size you need a full queen
king queen queen oh we've got a big
census so you know needs to be sturdy
oh [ __ ] gets kind of crazy in my room
her tears well this is a Posturepedic
mattress we got right here this
extremely comfortable and durable do you
mind if I try it no I'll go here I say
all submission is a 100% money-back
guarantee on yeah no it's too hard
natural latex mattresses it's on sale
too today $1,200
can I try it okay no what's the no
pricing I don't no problem we got other
choices this is a great memory foam
mattress right here it's a little
cheaper and I'm sorry it out right you
know how it goes
I'll take Jordan Peele
master of tension right there yeah my
god that was so awkward and
keegan-michael key the master of the
hesitant weirded out like vocal flutter
yes I really want King and Michael key
to appear in a Jordan Peele movie Jordan
Peele go all out with a horror comedy
and bring keegan-michael key into the
picture
how about keegan-michael key directs one
and Jordan Peele stars and no yeah we go
I don't know about that we gotta get out
of the box now the deals already out of
the box doing multiple genres we got you
in the mix I love this sketch because
it's to not go at all how I thought it
was gonna be that's what they both do
they subvert the hell out of
expectations cuz I thought oh master
shopping this is probably gonna be a
very relatable scenario making fun of
people when they when they go match or
shopping I know what it's like to go
mattress shopping where you're hopping
into all the beds few times I've ever
tried tempur-pedic some always like I'm
gonna get one one day I'm gonna get one
one day spent $4,000 on this mattress
and I thought this was a really
well-written comedy because I'm always
hearing it about like touching yourself
at the mattress store or doing it with
someone at one of the beds I got I'm
always hearing some dude crack that joke
right this went down a completely
awkward introverted path I personally
thought was great and I love how usually
the one who's yeah like I think you said
okay no Michael Kia noticing the
sketches is that V truly socially
awkward characters will probably go to
Jordan Peele most of the time and the
ones reacting to the weirdness
it's usually keegan-michael key usually
when that dynamic is flipped and that
usually means keegan-michael key is
probably like really bombastic over
there loud or they're completely
matching each other's energy on that
level because I didn't have Comedy
Central so my only experience with key
and Peele has always been through
YouTube I think was it was a year so it
introduced me to the first sketch
ever-watchful is put the [ __ ] you
showed me that scale I showed you that
would show me that it's such a funny a
sketch yeah there's so many classics in
their catalogue and man like they
revamped sketch comedy after a while cuz
I remember you know we have like mind of
Mencia and we had other shows you know a
good chunk of time before but we sure
the appeal came back I really think they
smash the door open for a comedy again
and yeah I mean there's such good
character actors and this did not go the
way I expected it to I didn't expect to
feel bad for this guy I want to know how
this sketch was conceived because the
idea of going to shop for a mattress
that you need durability for because of
other people's activities is such a
wacky concept that I yeah I just want to
know how they arrived at that because
it's such a specific problem to have
well it seems like it's twofold you
always get Jordan Pio who it seems to
always have a psychological angle I'm
not just saying that because of the
horror tour that he is now it's always
been present in the sketches and there
might be like multiple meanings to that
ending bit honestly yeah one is what you
said just the joke of what if a guy is
actually getting a mattress just so he
can withstand his neighbors their
activities right and then you got the
other side of it where he's acting it
out when he's in the mattress store so
maybe there's this like lonely's
introverted side of him that is living
vicariously through them so he wanted to
get the right mattress so he can
experience that this deviant he's come
across to somebody else in the world
like he's the one who's given that good
D live in those shoes for a hot second
but in Stern appealing I bet when ya
peel open that banana it is a good D oh
yeah when you get the key to that joke
it's there's a D inside it's great video
put an ad on okay we haven't said
anything was a nerd
getting margin so we're okay yeah we
didn't say anything you can't say on
television yeah we didn't say though the
one name of that thing that apparently
YouTube does not want you talking about
even though it's the most talked about
thing in the world did you see Jordan
Peele put out a revised to get out
poster that says stay in Chris on the
chair Julie uh oh no do not
yeah well I'm asking some pasta that's
hilarious it see though he's still funny
even now that they've stopped comedy
they're still funny all right guys well
what's your favorite key and Peele
sketch what do you think is the most
underrated sketch you want to see
keegan-michael key joined some Jordan
Peele horror movie I know you do leave
your thoughts down below
make sure to subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification better
get notified we're never got a YouTube
video a big thanks again a SiteLock for
sponsoring this video and last but not
least ascend this with a chamber Zane I
am skipping around in the rain I am
splishing and splashing and whipping and
lashing wishing and laughing that this
phone is water-resistant as they say Oh
Delia I feel yeah when you're talking
about typography I don't actually have
that I feel badass and compare myself
but you're prolific with your writing
man and you've got such a great
perspective point of view personality I
cannot wait to the day where you are
slinging books going on tour man drop
the fat page it's gonna be awesome but
for right now I just want to send you
some love and thank you for being here
with us and for singing in the rain with
me
Leah I'll see you on the next video
much love my dear be well